the Jaguar has several threats now in
Mexico habitat loss the perception of
Jaguar as a threat to livestock and then
illegal hunting the question is how do
you protect the most elusive animal of
the Yucatan Peninsula by photographing
and filming these elusive cats we have
generated the basis for the acquisition
of additional land and the protection of
this crucial Jaguar corridor we named
this place el either
we acquire the land in 1993 and due to
the inaccessibility we are in a very
pristine area Ellie then is unique in
that is immersed in a continual systems
of wetlands and Forests therefore it
still has a large and good number of
light life populations that is crucial
for understanding Jaguars in the wild
yeah we're going to open the case and
check out the LD card see what we have
the first time we saw this Jaguar it was
really something that changed the course
of what le them has been doing over the
years we have set up over 300 cameras
these cameras have generated over 2,500
photographs of Jaguars under prey right
now we have probably 37 42 Jaguars
documented in the region and we have new
ones coming out so we said this is
something that's going to aid us in
conservation the Jaguar has been a very
strong cultural icon in Mexico for the
Mayans it was a symbol of Frank's power
in Mexico we know today we have about
4,500 Jaguars by enabling the Jaguar as
our conservation icon we can bring
attention strong enough to protect
certain areas or change certain patterns
of development endangered species are a
key element to protect we have put them
endangered we need to reverse that it's
our responsibility it's our challenge
people are thrilled once you show them
the actual animals in their environment
and how many they are that's when people
change their views and go for
conservation the big horse of a male
definitely an adult